now I know this isn't your first horror
film is it so you're a bit of a pro
because you've been in the hole as well
with keira knightley man years ago I was
in about 17 yeah how did the seasoning
house compare in terms of horror for you
what I think it felt much more horror
because my scenes were very violent so
so yeah I really felt like I was in a
horror film because there was a lot of
blood and I had to fight and use a knife
do you have to kind of prepare yourself
physically as well as mentally to a role
like this I tried to keep myself fit I
had a baby and about 10 months ago so I
wasn't feeling that fit but but yeah I
try and keep it yeah just in case you
know this is off tonight kill you ride a
horse can you you know sword fights so
you've got to be able to do all those
things my part Alexa she is some of the
angel finds towards the end of the film
pulled was it her angels Hansel and
Gretel moment so her house is a real
relief after seeing what's been
happening you think Oh angel is safe you
know and all the colors are different
you know I wear like a bright pink and
fluffy sort of talk with little white
socks and pretty hair and you think you
know so actually the house itself was
quite was okay compared to all the other
scenes
but then it gets really messy this table
smashed and and that was horrible lying
in a pool of blood for about three hours
and then having a cold shower afterwards
no that was not nice no glamour being
actresses it it's not whether you you've
got to be you've got to be really
hardcore to be an actor and what's up
what's up next for you because I know
you've got a few things coming up
haven't you there's a film with Eric
Bana Rebecca Hall that you've been
shooting can you research yes closed and
then another horror film or
psychological thriller called in fear so
those two coming out yeah he told us a
little bit about each of those what your
role in them and we be doing enclosed
and it's a sort of law Lord Rama I went
going to it too much because we're at
fright fest okay eric bana's ex-wife
[ __ ] and I'm a [ __ ] in it and in fear
it was an improvised piece and three
people in it sorry for people in it
second Cornwall or films in Cornwall and
yeah I don't want to sort of give away
that one cuz I in case you see it it's
really going to be great yeah I look
forward to seeing both those we was in
like working with you know big stars
like Eric Bana Rebecca Hall eric bana is
very professional and lovely and just
very nice yeah it's lovely to speak to
Gemma and lots of lower the seating
house and the view the films as well
thank you
you